What is it?
>> What's the What's the first one?
Learn this part.
It's just too fun.
>> Terrible. I hate it.
[laughter]
Not only like a long time.
It's close, but it's still
This is what this is what they're
going to put.
I didn't
perfect.
You're not going to be able to
Hey, it takes a real
That would be awesome.
Hello lovely people. How are you all? I
am Jared. My pronouns are he, they. Um,
hello to my online friends as well. It's
lovely to see you. Um, [music] I have a
few announcements as we get going
tonight and then I will help transition
us into worship with the amazing worship
team and sounds do all they do.
>> So, um, announcements. Uh, our next five
low service day. So, if you don't know,
we volunteer at the food pantry here
locally. Um, that day is going to be on
December 6th. The kicker is you have to
sign up by tomorrow so you can get
screened or logged into the system
correctly so they can have you help. So
if you would like to help um do that,
you need to register tomorrow. You can
do that via the QR link QR code. Um and
we'd love to have your help with that,
especially in this uh kind of peculiar
time where not all the normal assets
might be available to people because the
government. Um
so also um save the date. So since we
have a unique situation here with First
Methodist Saxi, Christmas Eve is not
available to us on the actual day. So we
will be doing Christmas Eve service on
December 21st at 5:00 p.m. So um please
uh it'll be a family-friendly service
complete with carols and a candle
lighting ceremony. Um, please mark your
calendars and invite your friends and
family to join us on December 21st for
Christmas Eve service. Um, speaking of
lighting candles, we've lit some candles
here to remind us of the presence of
Jesus and the everpresent spirit. Um, as
we enter into worship. So, as we exit
the kingdom of noise, hurry, and
productivity,
now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
Sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship, and adoration.
A place to behold Christ, revelation of
God, heartbeat of creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
Thanks, Jared. If you guys would stand
with us, we're going to spend some time
worshiping together. Um, I don't know
how many of you were here last week, but
we [music] had the privilege of some of
our youth leading us in worship, and
they introduced us to this new song. Um,
and so that's going to be part of our
set tonight. [music]
And, uh, I just encourage you guys to
sing along if you know the songs. And if
you don't, um, pay attention to the
words and let those do a work in your
heart. Um, let the hope and the
encouragement [music] from them lift you
up. and whatever you might bring be
bringing into this space tonight,
[music] it is welcome here. So, uh this
is a time for us to bring our full
selves and [music] interact and um
worship can be something that you're
just taking in, but it also can be an
opportunity for you to
>> [music]
>> um be fully embodied and lift your hands
um or open up your posture [music] even.
The more that we incorporate our full
self into this moment, the more that we
get out of [music] it. So, I just
encourage you guys, it's a safe space
and um try connecting in a new way
tonight [music] as uh as you're
interacting with this spiritual
experience of of a God who loves us and
singing words about them that we believe
to be true. All right.
[music]
[bell]
>> [music]
[music]
>> Where [singing] can we run?
Where can [music] we hide?
[singing] You will not find us.
In the deepest of depths
[singing and music]
and the highest of heights,
your love it chasees
[music and singing] us.
No matter where we remain, [music]
no matter what we've done,
we can [singing] escape
your love.
>> [music]
>> Oh,
and we will [singing] never see the end.
We will never see the
[music and singing] end
of your goodness.
[singing]
We will never see the end. [singing] We
will never see [music] the end
of [singing] your
[music]
day.
Oh,
[music] and though we pass through the
fire [singing]
and we pass through the flood,
you [music and singing] will be with
us.
Leave us through the valley.
[music and singing]
In the darkest of nights,
your love will be [music] our light.
And when we are in [music] plenty and
when we are [singing] in want,
you will [music] always be.
[singing]
Oh, [music]
we will [singing] never see the end. We
will never see the end
of your goodness. [singing]
[music]
We will never see the end. [singing] We
will never see the end
[music] of your [singing] goodness.
>> [music]
>> Hey, [singing]
[music]
[music and singing]
and in the darkest hour and on the
darkest day,
We [singing] do not have to be afraid.
[music] For you'll never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises that [music] you have made.
[singing]
And in our darkest hour and on our
[singing] hardest day,
we do not have to be afraid.
>> [singing]
>> For you'll never leave.
You will not [singing] forsake
the promises that you
[music and singing]
have made.
And we [singing] will say
that we [music]
will never [singing]
see the end. We will never see the end
of your [music and singing] goodness.
We will never see [singing] the end. We
will never see the end
of your good. Let's sing that one more
time. [music]
And we [singing]
will never see the end. We will never
see the end [music] of your [singing]
goodness.
No, we will [singing] never see the end.
We will never [music] see the end
of your goodness.
All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to the kids ministry classes. You
can meet your teachers over here by
these double doors.
Hi.
[laughter]
Hey.
[clears throat]
And we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people.
Um I think most of you have been here
before, but if you haven't, up on the
screens we have
space
to just sit on your heart tonight
and that God wants to carry those
burdens with us and then we'll [music]
close out the prayer again at the end.
Jesus, for this city of Sax, Texas, and
for every city and community, and all
who live in them, we pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us, and
[music] the wisdom and the will to
conserve it. We pray to you for the old
and the sick, for the widow and the
orphan, for the injured and suffering.
We pray [music] to you for the poor and
the oppressed, the unemployed and
destitute, for prisoners [music] and
captives and all who remember and care
for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. [music]
And for those struggling with mental and
emotional health, we pray to you, Lord.
We know that you love us and that you
hear us. So we lift these names and
situations [music] up to you.
For the names in the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence. Amen.
It doesn't matter.
[singing]
I will be [music] with you, my God.
I will [singing] stay with you.
It doesn't matter if the whole [singing]
world [music]
turns
away. I will stay [singing] with you, my
God,
I will stay with you. Let's [music] sing
that again. It doesn't matter if the
whole world [music]
turns [singing]
away. I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
It [music and singing] doesn't matter if
the whole world turns [singing] away. I
[music] will stay with you, my God.
I will [singing] stay with you.
For where [music] can I go? Where can I
go? Where can I go? [singing]
If only [music] you have the words of
life. Only you have the words [singing]
of life. [music] Where can I go? Where
can I go? Where can I go? [singing]
When only [music] you have the words of
life? Only [singing] you have the words.
>> [music]
>> It [singing] doesn't matter if the whole
world turns [singing]
away. [music] I will stay with you, my
God.
I [singing] will stay with you.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns [singing]
away. I will stay [music] with you. My
God,
I will stay with you.
Where can I go? Where can I go? Where
can I [singing and music] go?
When only you have the words [singing]
of life? Only you have the words of
life. Where can I go? Where can I
[music and singing] go? Where can I go?
And [music and singing] only you have
the words of life. Only you have the
words [singing]
of life.
>> [music]
>> No other [singing] wealth's going to
satisfy. [music]
No other words going to be my life. No
other love that [singing] I'm turning
[music]
to. Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
No other wealth's going
[music and singing] to satisfy.
No other word's going to be my [music]
life. No other world that [singing] I'm
turning to. Jesus, you're [music] my
Let's sing that one more time. No
[singing] other world's going to sisfy.
No other world's going to be my light.
No other love [singing] that I'm turning
to. Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
Jesus, [singing] you're my breakthrough.
Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
[music]
It [music and singing] doesn't matter if
the whole world turns
away. I will [music] stay with [singing]
you, my God.
I will stay with [music] you.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away.
I will stay with you, my
[singing and music] God.
I will stay with you.
Cuz where can I go? Where [singing] can
I go? Where can I go?
When [singing] only you have the words
of life? Only [music] you have the words
of life. Where can I go? [singing] Where
can I go? Where can I go?
With [music and singing] only you have
the words of life. Only you have [music]
the words of life. Only [singing] you
have the words of life. Only [music] you
have the words of life. Only you have
the words of life. Only you have the
words of life.
This week was um one of our not not
easiest [music] weeks in my family. We
had a lot of sickness going through the
household, some disappointments. It was
just kind of one thing after another, it
felt like um and one of the things that
I hang on to in in those moments where
you just feel exhausted, you're sleepd
deprived, you know. Um it's just some of
some of the things that I remember from
the Bible like his mercies are new every
morning. some of those words that just
sustain you. You know, I'm the bread of
life. Those little phrases from his word
that just where else can I go when when
I'm at the end of my rope and I'm broken
down, I'm tired, I'm discouraged,
it's just his word [music] that
sometimes gets me through that next
moment. Or even just his mercy, knowing
that I fail, [music] but then I can get
back up. You know, like I'm the author
and the perfector of your faith.
the good shepherd
knowing that he's with us, that he goes
before us, that he's behind us, he's our
rear guard.
And it's it's in those moments when you
feel like you have nothing left to give
that sometimes [music] for me, I feel
like he becomes enough.
He is sustaining us. He is pulling us
forward.
And you can find some gratitude in that
even whenever everything seems to be
going wrong.
There is this kind of broken hallelujah
that can ring out when you make it to
the end. When you lay your head down for
the night, even if it's a sleepless
night, and you just know there's going
to be a new day, a new dawn, [music] and
he's still going to be there.
And God, our father, our mother, she's
still going to be pulling us [music]
forward, covering us in her wings,
sheltering us in the storm.
This song is called gratitude, and
Jesse's [music] going to lead it. Um, so
tonight, whatever you might be facing, I
just encourage you
to try to find just even if it's
something small, something [music] that
you're grateful for, and just hang on to
that. Let it be [music] an anchor of
hope in your storm tonight.
All my words fall short [singing]
and I've got nothing new.
How could I express
all my [singing]
gratitude?
And [music] I could sing these [singing]
songs
as I ofen,
but every song must end. [singing]
And you never do.
So I throw [music and singing] up my
hands and praise you again and again.
Cuz all that I [music and singing]
have is a hallelujah.
[music]
And [singing] I know it's not much, but
I'm nothing else fit for a king
except [music] for a heart singing
hallelujah.
Hallelujah. [singing]
[singing and music]
I've got [music and singing] one
response.
I've [music and singing] got just one
with [music] my [singing] arms stretched
wide.
I [music] will [singing]
worship you, Lord.
So I throw up my hands
[music and singing]
and praise you again and again.
[singing]
Cuz all [music] that I have is a
hallelujah.
Hallelujah. [music]
[singing]
And I know it's [music] not much, but
I'm nothing else fit for a king [music]
except for [singing] a heart singing
hallelujah.
[music]
[singing]
Hallelujah.
[music]
>> [music]
>> Come [singing] on my soul. Oh, don't you
get shy [music] of me. Lift up your soul
cuz you've got a lion inside [music]
[singing] of those lungs. Give up and
praise the Lord.
[music and singing]
Oh come on my soul. Oh don't you shine
lift up your soul.
You got [singing and music] light inside
of us.
Give [music and singing] up and praise
the Lord.
on my soul. Oh, don't you be shining
gift of [singing] your soul. [music] You
got light inside [singing] of us.
Get up and praise [music] the Lord.
Heat. Heat. [music]
[music]
So I throw [music] up my hands.
Praise you [singing] again and again.
Cuz all that I have [music and singing]
is a heart.
Hallelujah.
[singing]
I know [music] it's not much, but I'm
nothing else fit for a king [music]
except for a heart [singing] singing
hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
[music]
God, thank you that you are good,
that you are for us and not against us.
that you pull us out of our muk and our
meer and you set our feet on a rock.
Thank you that you gather your children
from all four corners of the earth
and you pull us together under your
wing.
You shelter us.
You comfort us.
God, tonight we're grateful for that
kind of love.
Would that gratitude carry us through
this next week,
through every hard moment, every dark
day?
God, would your light guide us?
Would it rise up within us like a song?
Would it lift our heads?
God, would we remember to go to your
word? And would it be a lamp unto our
feet and a light unto our path
because only you have the words of life.
God, help us to remember to turn to you.
our everpresent help in times of
trouble.
We love you, God, and we invite [music]
you into this space with us tonight.
Would you speak to our hearts?
Would you remind us who's we are?
It's in your name I pray. Amen.
Thank you guys for singing with us. If
y'all would turn to the person on your
right and left and say, "The peace of
Christ be with you."
Well, grace and peace. It is so good to
be with you all. My name is Brett.
Pronouns he him. And uh yeah, it's a joy
a joy to welcome you into the space as
always. That includes those joining us
online. Love youall lots. And anyone
here tonight who is new, if this is your
first time or just your first time, you
know, in a long time. Um we're really
really glad that you're you're here with
us among us. Um so let's see. The title
of my message this week is when
everything is shaken. And uh if you've
been a part of the table for a while,
you know we tend to do different types
of series. Sometimes we'll go through
like a book of the Bible. Sometimes
we'll do something more topical like our
last two series have been kind of more
on like a topic. And other times we will
just jump into uh what's known as the
church calendar basically um kind of
joining in. I think it's important to
kind of join in with a larger church in
certain times and seasons. Uh so we tend
to follow the United Methodists even
though technically we're not United
Methodists though we you might be fooled
since we meet you in a building but um
but I I do love their liturgy and uh
their kind of lectionary readings. So
there's kind of you know certain
scriptures that are prescribed for
various times. So the next two weeks
will be kind of some one-off messages
and we're going to be following the
lectionary in those. And uh part of the
reason I love that is not only the sense
of joining in with the broader church,
but uh also it kind of will kind of
nudge me into different areas, topics,
you know, like you never know what's
coming out of like the reading. Like I
just I'm as like, you know, kind of uh
intrigued as you like when I just kind
of pull it up like, "All right, well,
let's see what the passages are this
week, you know, and just like the Old
Testament readings and the Psalm and the
Gospel reading and then the Epistle and
from the New Testament." And so I just,
you know, choose from one of those. Um
but it's uh it never ceases. I don't
know. There's always something um
beautiful and insightful in these these
texts. So um it's also a good time to
jump on the church calendar because
we're coming into the season of like
advent and then like Christmas tide and
then Lent and you Easter and all that
that whole season. So we tend to to kind
of be more in the church calendar in
this next you know coming five six
months or so. Um so with that in mind
our gospel reading this week is from
Luke chapter 21 uh verses 5-6. So quite
a short uh little little text. It says
this. Some of his disciples were
remarking about how the temple was
adorned with beautiful stones and with
gifts dedicated to God.
But Jesus said, "As for what you see
here, the time will come when not one
stone will be left on another.
Every one of them will be thrown down."
So this passage it may strike us as I
don't know one of the more kind of
strange or kind of cryptic you know
sayings of Jesus and we might wonder
like I don't know how does this have
anything to do with you know our own
lives and our own kind of moment uh but
I think there's a lot more than meets
the eye going on here so to kind of
understand what's going on in this short
little narrative u we need to first
understand some background and some
history so basically it's a it's a
history about the temple and how
absolutely
central and essential um it was to the
the Jewish people, the Judaism of uh
Christ's time and era. So um the the
temple we have some images here. So the
this first one is um the temple was
completed for the first time in 957
um BCE uh under King Solomon. So it was
like the absolute crown jewel of not
only Jewish like religion at that time
but really you know political life,
social life, cultural life. I mean it
was just the the center of everything,
the center of Jerusalem and the center
of of their really their whole
existence. Uh, and that's why it was so
absolutely crushing when it was
destroyed 370 years later by the
conquering Babylonian Empire uh in 587
B.CE. If you want to get like a little
bit of a feel for just what a absolute
catastrophe that was in the hearts and
minds of uh God's people living at that
time, you can go read the book of
Lamentations in the Bible. It was
written right after the destruction of
the temple. You can hear the word lament
in that title lamentations, right? And
it it is a a book of lament. Um though
also interesting that kind of
acknowledgement of the goodness of God.
Actually the quote one of the scriptures
Mindy quoted um about the steadfast love
the Lord never cease seen his mercies
never come to an end. They're new every
morning. Great is thy faithfulness Lord.
That's actually like from Lamentations
3. But but but that's you know that's
few and far between the book of
Lamentations. Mostly it is like oh my
gosh God where are you? Right? This just
was an absolute national catastrophe
and the ruins of the temple stood for
nearly 50 years. So the way the
Babylonians kind of went about this
whenever they conquered a people they
basically took like all of the kind of
educated like elites and the business
leaders and the the priests and I mean
just sort of everyone who was sort of at
least in the kind of running the society
so to speak. everyone and they they
would take them all off back to Babylon
to kind of bolster the empire. Um and
they would leave maybe a few thousand um
peasants and folks there in Jerusalem.
So there were some Jewish people that
remained there but you know by and large
it was mostly the people were exiled. So
that's why the temple just stood it was
just in ruins. They didn't have the
people power to like do anything. So it
stood um in ruins for 50 years until
miracle of miracles um Cyrus the great
uh who was uh king of Persia at the
time. There was kind of just empire
after empire. If you read the Bible,
it's really in a way a history of the
ancient near east and it's just the
story of the Assyrians and the
Babylonians and then the Mes and then
the Persians and and eventually we'll
get to the Romans, right? It's just
empire after empire conquering
conquering conquering. So, uh, once the
Persians came to power, they actually,
Miracle of Miracles, they let some of
the Jewish people, um, a huge contingent
of them return home.
And what do you think was the first
thing they set about doing,
rebuilding that temple, uh, which they
were, I mean, the work basically began
immediately. It was completed, um, 22
years later, 517 B.CE. So from kind of
that first destruction at the end it was
like 70 years that it kind of stood
there um and was finally rebuilt. By
some accounts this is known as the
second temple. Um not quite as glorious
as the first one partly be just just
because you know culturally like they
didn't like Solomon and that first
building the temple that was like the
peak of their wealth and power and you
know so they could just put so much into
that temple. The second one right you
can see because the history they didn't
quite have the same resources. Um,
nonetheless though, it was a remarkable
structure like especially for its time,
you know, I mean, just absolutely
beautiful. Um, incredible. And, uh,
again, it served as the very heart of
of, uh, Judaism and and the Jewish faith
in life there. Just everything to the
people. And there that second temple
stood for over 500 years. Just think of
that scope of time. you know like even
here in the US you know we don't haven't
even been around for h barely half that
you know what I mean um so 500 years it
had stood by the time we reached the
days when Christ and his disciples
walked those dusty streets and this is
why the disciples turn to Jesus and say
just look at it isn't it beautiful isn't
it stunning and look at the people's
devotion
like look how they bring their their
gifts dedicated to God here. What a
perfect place. Truly, the Lord is with
us. And how do we know kind of by
implication what they're saying? You
know, the kind of text underneath the
text is because of this remarkable
building, this holy place, right? You
can see how it was this just central
powerful
symbol. And I don't know how the word
symbol that resonates with you, but like
symbols to human beings are everything,
you know? I mean, this is why someone
like burns an American flag. You're
like, "Oh, it's just a piece of cloth."
It's it's a symbol, right? It it
symbolizes
sort of the nation, the you know what I
mean to to where which is why that the
destruction of the temple. It wasn't
just like, "Oh man, our favorite
building got knocked out." Like, no, no,
it was everything, right? Uh, and so now
this is why it resonates with them. It's
this powerful symbol effect in a lot of
ways like here in the US, you know, we
have kind of our own of course symbols
deeply meaningful to us, but I don't
know if anything has quite the the
symbolic power. It would almost be like
religiously like if you were Mormon and
you had like the the Mormon the temple
there in Salt Lake City, kind of like
combine that with like the Lincoln
Memorial, combine that with like the 911
memorial in New York, you know? It's
like and just combine the kind of
religious, political, social symbolism
all into one. And like that's the
meaning and the passion they had for uh
this this symbol. It it really it came
for them it really came to be a source
of um of deep profound kind of pride. Um
not just in a negative sense though you
could argue kind of over time um that
did kind of set in. Um but it was almost
I think the the challenge with it it
almost became a kind of extension of
their um kind of identity
right in the same way our symbols right
we this happens to us too right we human
beings we love our symbols and they
become a kind of extension of us
and it's almost like the mindset was
we're great because that's great
so
this is why Jesus receive response
though is so absolutely like surprising
in that basically he doesn't he doesn't
say kind of par it back to them yes it
really is remarkable you know I'm
confident I'm confident it will stand
for generations to come
no what is did you catch it in the story
what does he say he's like a day will
come when not one stone will be left
upon another sure enough about 40 years
after that moment
during the Jewish Roman war the Romans
demolished the second temple in
Jerusalem it has not been rebuilt to
this very day.
So what what does this mean you know for
us for our own kind of day our own time?
I might want to kind of get us thinking
in in this way by naming that humans
like in essence we're not so different
from them. Humans were always looking
for refuge
a kind of bull work against the chaos a
safe harbor from the storm we call life.
I think architecture often reflects
this. You know, there's a reason that we
want our political, religious, and
cultural institutions to look
unshakable.
We have a a few examples of this um as
well. If we could put up those those
images, right? Churches, banks, the New
York Stock Exchange, the National
Archives in Washington DC, right? It's
it's very much on purpose that things
these things are not built in like in a
frail little building like a strip mall,
right? No, no, no, no. That why? Because
the architecture itself speaks, right?
What's that architecture? What is it?
What is it saying to you as you look at
that? It's in essence, it's
communicating, hey, we aren't going
anywhere. Look at these pillars. Look at
this stone. You You think You think
these are falling down tomorrow?
You think you can destroy this? Oh, just
try. You cannot. No one can. Why? What's
it communicating? It's saying because
we're timeless. Because we're
trustworthy. Because we're unshakable.
And we will be here. We will be here for
you and your kids and your grandkids and
generations to come. You can count on
us.
You say, "You see all that in those
stones?" I do. That's what I That's what
I I do think like this is where
architecture weirdly influences us, you
know, in ways we're not even like
consciously aware of. But it it speaks.
Now, of course, it's way beyond
architecture alone, right? It's all
sorts of cultural kind of rhythms and
liturgies. We see it in the solemn oaths
that we take at various points in our
lives. you know, we if you join the
armed forces,
uh it's not just some kind of like,
yeah, I think I'll give this a whirl,
you know, like no, there's you swear to
something, right? You commit yourself to
something. It's similar um with
marriage, of course, right? Till death
do us part and such. We see it in
religion, too, right? the various
symbols and theologies and uh things
people kind of like one person for
example in our story they hang their hat
on the temple in Jerusalem another in
the Catholic hierarchy right Protestant
kind of Christians in the Bible as a
kind of perfect document at least some
uh Protestants uh Muslims in the Quran
as a flawless text
we see it very much in the political
world right now in other words this
isn't just a religious thing. Uh people
I think can sense the ties that bind us
fraying. I don't often get pulled into
Facebook kind of comments and such, but
occasionally I feel prompted to speak
out and some of you may have seen a few
weeks ago I felt kind of prompted to
chime in on uh some of where I see this
playing out in the culture and I what I
think are kind of dangerous ways. Um,
but some what I was trying to speak to
there was there's a kind of anxiety in
the nation and there's a there's a lot
of political polarization
and a lot of change and so people react
right and there's a kind of almost an
overreaction where we say well look God
is for us and our nation state will
endure.
Uh for example, there was a recent
political and religious gathering where
I was struck by what one of the speakers
there said. They said, "Western
civilization will endure."
And then they said, "And we," and they
inserted the name of their political
organization. They said, "And we will
last forever."
I think that's quite a statement,
right? But but this is what humans human
beings do, right? We we need or at least
we feel we need these these kinds of
symbols and structures and kind of roots
to kind of ground ourselves,
right?
And in so many ways that phrase, it
sounds just like the disciples in Luke
21.
Look at what we've built.
Look at it. It's so beautiful. It's so
powerful.
To which Jesus responds,
you see, humans were always looking for
that refuge, that bull work against the
chaos. I think this is where the
Christian saints and mystics are.
They're helpful,
but they're also gadflies.
you know, they're they're helpful
because they see further than we do.
And and they basically kind of warn us.
They're like, "Careful,
don't do it. Don't put your ultimate
hope in these things.
Put your hope in God, the source, the
foundation, the ground of all things,
the only one who does not change.
And so at times, right, they kind of
like Jesus um they sound kind of harsh
like they sound they're just like
they're cold comfort to us just like the
disciples. They wanted a better response
than actually no not one's own will be
left upon you. This is not what they
were looking for you know uh but it was
the message they needed.
It was good medicine because Christ is
naming that these institutions and
systems that we build the these
institutions and buildings and
traditions whether religious or
political or you know all of all the
cultural things that we do as human
beings that that those things say
everything's fine. We have everything
under control. You can trust us. We'll
be here forever. [laughter]
And Christ is just warning us, naming
like, "Huh?" Here's the truth. These
things are human. Oh, so human. They are
beautiful
and flawed. They are good
and bad. They are fragile.
Oh, so fragile. More fragile than anyone
would ever care to admit. Certainly more
fragile than that architecture
would try and communicate.
Now, I I do think there's there's kind
of political implications, you know, for
Christians to what Jesus is naming here.
You know, I I do I think Christians can
and should participate in civic life, in
political life. I think that's um that's
good. Um, and at the same time, in light
of Jesus kind of words here, I think at
the same time, we can't become too
enthralled
by it, right? In essence, should not put
all our hope in it. And that's some of
what I'm kind of seeing in the broader
culture right now where there's a lot of
from that place of anxiety. There's a
lot of um kind of emphasis being placed
on these humanos so human institutions
and such as A KIND OF BULL WORK that we
can trust and rely on forever. And it's
like you're going to be so disappointed.
Um this is only the language we should
reserve for God and God alone. So I do
think there's kind of social political
implications here. Um, but where I want
to actually take this is somewhere a
little bit more personal because
sometimes we can keep that critique a
little bit out there outside the walls
like oh yeah those people they really
have that problem you know but good
thing we don't. Um and I I think I want
to turn this a little more towards
myself um and us to say like well what
what can we really glean from this and
what I would want to name is I think in
a way um these kind of we might call
institutional egos which is kind of
interesting to think of like communities
having a kind of collective ego. I found
this idea very helpful. Um I think in a
way institutional egos are a kind of
mirror. They're like a reflection of the
personal egos that make them up. In
other words, in the same way a church or
a bank or a nation state is kind of
constantly trying to communicate, you
know, this sense of [clears throat] like
don't worry, everything's fine. We got
this. Uh we're in control. It's great.
It's great. It's great. We're good.
We're good. you know, um I think human
beings as individuals, we do this too.
Uh I mean, I do this too, right? And and
this is what scripture though refers to
um as kind of the false self or we might
call it the egoic self. basically this
this kind of weird uh part of us that
tends to use people and positions and
titles to kind of try and like construct
this narrative this story about ourself
and of course the narrative kind of
differs for all of us you know but
there's like we're not like that
creative you know what I mean like in
the end uh there's similar themes you
know it's something like I am this is
again it's about identity so I'm worthy
I'm valuable
because
now this is where we tend to go wrong,
right? Because it is true that you are
valuable and worthy and loved because
God loves you. Because God sees you,
because God sustains you, right? That's
the truth. But this is where we take it
is no. I I'm worthy. I'm valuable. I'm
loved because and it's something outside
my because my kids are so good. You say,
"I've seen your kid." Well, most of the
time my voice can get a little crazy,
but my kids are so good, you know. Um,
because
uh because of how productive I am or
this one, we love like the material
possessions because of just, you know,
just look at my car. Look at my clothes
or look at what neighborhood I live in
or look at where I work. You wouldn't
believe the degrees, you know, what we
just have these things. We're constantly
telling the story about, you know, uh,
grounding our self and identity. The
way, um, Thomas Merin put it, uh, is
this. He said, "All sin starts from the
assumption that my false self, the self
that exists only in my own egocentric
desires, is the fundamental reality of
life to which everything else in the
universe is ordered."
It's a that's a profound quote. In
essence, right, we start to kind of
think like we it's almost like we tell
this story that's like sort of a
fiction, but then we believe it and then
we like live our whole life from as
though the whole world centers around
that truth only the problem is not even
true. You you know this is where we get
all weird. Uh and again we can do this
sort of socio kind of sociopolitically
you know or we do it individually.
I'm great where you know because of all
these this this story.
Now there is good news though initially
I admit it may sound like bad news which
is why folks like Jesus and a lot of the
teachers and saints and mystics down
through the centuries often sound to us
kind of like negative you know but it's
it's actually because they're trying to
set us free right from these shackles
that by so it sounds like oh you're a
downer but he says no they're a downer
on the fakeness on the falseness on what
is not true you know what I mean so it's
it's actually quite good but it sounds
bad so here's kind of how I might frame
the good news at some point.
By the way, even if it's at death,
because I think death is like the
ultimate letting go moment, at some
point my false self is shaken and
collapses until not one stone is left
upon another.
It might be from illness. Some of you
have have been through this, are in the
midst of it right now.
uh illness, job loss, marital breakdown,
adult children now out of your control,
workcoholism, some other ism, addiction,
right? It it may even simply be from a
kind of a feeling of failure, you know,
of like you've told yourself this story,
then you haven't even been able to live
up to like the story. U that's the one I
personally resonate with with um this
kind of has been continues to be how my
own false self like rears its ugly head.
I've told this in some various sermons,
so I won't go into like all the details
again, but basically I just I tend to be
someone with like these sort of high
standards for myself and with a certain
insecurity
in my at times failure to reach them and
live into them. And like the way this
plays out is I'm always looking for like
some future moment
when I will arrive.
Anyone there waiting for the day when
you will arrive?
You know, like this time when my egoic
project shall be complete. A time when
I'll finally have the admiration of
everyone [laughter] around me. It's
completely ridiculous, you know, but I
this is what I long for, you know, and
then I'll know. Then I'll know I'm
enough.
I'm enough.
Ah, but thanks be to God. He has
thwarted every plan of mine. [laughter]
And slowly but surely, it's a process,
you know. I'm I'm dying to that as I
realize, ah crap, it's my false self.
It's this fake egoic weird little
insecure story. I'm like trying to
convince everyone else and myself of,
you know, it's ridiculous.
I'm just trying to plant my flag
somewhere.
I had a I met with a friend a few weeks
ago and uh great guy, one of the just
smartest people I know. Um very
successful. He's founded like multiple
like tech companies and just kind of one
of those people that like is like easy
to be jealous of like kind of has it
all, you know, just has wonderful like
wife and family and job and money and
you know all this stuff. And so we got
coffee and uh of course you know to kind
of open up like hey how how are you? How
you been? It had been quite a while
since we got together and I've learned
in these moments partly it's through
this journey of like trying to not be so
fake and you know tell this oh great
great man great oh yeah you know um
learning to be like honest you know
[laughter] so I said you know I mean
overall I'm I'm blessed I have a good
life um but I won't lie the last two
years it's been real challenging
and I said I think I think at this point
in my life you know kind of old middle
age is catching up to me I just I
expected I'm here I expected to be there
somewhere down there, you know, instead
I'm here and it's been so like hard and
at times a little even humiliating and
it's so challenging, you know, and it
was like in me kind of opening up it
seemed like it kind of I don't know I
gave him permission you know what I mean
how this will happen if you're a little
bit vulnerable than often other people
far from judging we often fear they're
gonna judge me and they're gonna be like
oh my gosh yeah yeah why are you such a
failure you know but no of course people
are like oh well me too you know what I
mean and it was like it opened up a
little space and He started to share and
he said um you know about a year and a
half ago I opened up to my wife in like
some very deep ways and I had to tell
her I am not who you think I am. He said
I confessed things to her that night
that I swore I would take to my grave.
He said but you know what that moment a
year and a half ago that has set me
free.
And I heard him speaking and I thought,
my goodness, that's it. Not one stone
left upon another.
That's the shaking.
That's the That's the crumbling.
We might put it like this. We could say
immature religion uses God
to inflate our institutional and
personal egos. Hey, hey, look at us.
Look at our institution. Look at our
church. Look at our temple. Look at our
country, our tribe. And of course, you
know, kind of a side effect. Hey, look
at me. You know, you wouldn't believe
how successful or whatever.
By grace, of course. All by grace.
Mature religion pops our false self like
a balloon. We become empty, empty,
empty.
But in that letting go, we fall into the
very arms of God and begin to receive
our identity as in our life as a gift.
We might say rather than trying to kind
of establish our sense of self through
our own kind of either social
nationalistic or religious, you know,
kind of striving um or even just our own
individual striving. We begin to receive
we receive
our life as a gift of God. Our identity
and rootedness as a gift of God. In
essence, the true temple,
in other words, your true identity never
consists of anything anyone can see,
which is what our ego would love, you
know, titles and positions and roles,
etc. It is and always has been and
always will be hidden with Christ in
God.
So, kind of in closing, how can we step
into this here? Um, one of our core
values at the table is vulnerability.
And so, here's the practice. I want to
invite you to engage at some point like
in the next, you know, week or two. Find
someone or a group of someone's who you
feel you can trust and share one level
deeper than you normally would.
Your egoic false self will hate this. it
will say this is very dangerous is a
huge problem you know like you're
humiliating yourself you know etc etc
the more crazy your mind's going the
more you know oh it's working you know
like this is a good this is a good path
um
and but what happens as you do this
you're you're learning to kind of
operate in that true self like look this
is just who I actually really am
in that kind of simplicity
you know maybe you've been attending a
meetup for months or years, but you kind
of keep those cards close to the chest.
You know what I mean? Or maybe you have
a spiritual director or a therapist or a
friend you like you share with, you
know, but you always kind of hold back.
There's levels, there's places you're
not willing to go. Man, I encourage you,
find someone you can trust and step into
that place of a of a willed
vulnerability, a kind of uh an a
transparency, an honesty.
When you do that, it will feel like a
shaking. I promise you, those stones
will tremble. But it's in that crumbling
that the false self begins to fall away.
And the true self is allowed to shine
forth, the Christlike self in each and
every one of us. In the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it. Eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." Then he held up a cup of wine.
He said, "Take this drink. This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me." And so as we come
forward, we're participating in that
mystery. We're remembering. We're
connecting with the crucified and risen
one. uh the one who accepts us just as
we are. So the way we'll participate in
communion tonight is we'll just start
here at the front. We'll go row by row
uh forming one line here in the middle.
So when one row is done, the next one
can go ahead and get in line. Um we
practice what's called an open table.
Meaning if you're here tonight and you'd
like to participate, then you are free
to do that regardless of your, you know,
exact like theology or denomination or
whatever. If something in you wants to
connect with Jesus, then you're you feel
free to um come forward. At the same
time, there's no pressure. If you'd
rather not, that's okay, too. You should
know the red is wine, the white is grape
juice. And finally, you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like. Some
folks like to come and kneel here at the
front. Um, others like to partake
immediately. Some return to their seats
for kind of a moment and then they take.
But no one will lead you through the
exact moment of taking. So, this is the
table, not of the church, but of the
Lord. And it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more. So come you who have much
faith and you who have little. You who
have been here often and you who have
not been here long. You who have tried
to follow and you who feel like you've
failed. Come. Come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
We're going to close with a song tonight
called Known and Loved. And we haven't
done it for quite a while. Um so you're
welcome to just sit back and reflect on
this song um if you would like. [music]
But the words of the chorus are very
simple and straightforward. It just
says, "We are known and loved." Known
and loved by you. And I just think about
that story that Brett was just telling
us about that guy who opened up about
things that he had never shared before.
[music] And um something that is a
comfort to me is knowing that there
isn't something in my life that God is
not already aware of. There's there is
no hiding. There's there's no use in
hiding from the one who created me, from
the one who made me. Um there is only
love there for [music] me. So I hope we
hold on to that this week. um as we um
as we dare to be vulnerable [music] like
Brett was saying and and uh share our
true self with with the people that
we're closest with. Um so Jesse's going
to lead us in this song and you guys are
welcome to sit back or [music] stand and
sing either one, but let's focus on
those words.
We've [music and singing] been hiding
in the shadows,
lost and afraid of you.
We've been wondering
in [singing and music] the darkness,
but if we only knew,
we are [music and singing] known and
loved.
Known and [music] loved. [singing]
We are known and loved by you.
>> [music]
>> You've been waiting [singing]
to show us [music] mercy.
Your presence [singing]
is our own.
>> We're [music and singing] your children.
Love forever
now.
>> [music and singing]
>> Every fear is gone.
We are [music and singing]
in love.
Known in love. We [singing and music]
are known in love by you. We are known.
We are known [music and singing]
in love.
Known in [music] love. [singing]
We are no.
There is [music and singing] no fear
anymore.
Lord in his mercy. [singing]
There is no fear in your love.
There [music and singing] is no fear
anymore [music and singing]
cuz you're the God of mercy.
There is no fear
[music] in your love
with your [music and singing]
mercy.
There is no fear [music]
anymore [singing]
cuz all is left is mercy. [singing]
There [music] is no fear
[singing] in your love.
In your love.
We are known [singing and music] in
love.
Known in love. We are known in love
[singing and music] by you.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Thank you so much for joining us
tonight. Um, if you were a visitor, um,
we would love if [music] you would, uh,
take a moment to fill out a visitor card
on the small table over there, or you
can fill it out with a QR code online if
you haven't done so [music] already. Um,
that just lets us know you were here,
and we like that. Um,
also of note, [music] um, Meetup groups,
Brett kind of mentioned them in the
service, but Meetup groups, uh, are
listed online at the QR code, but it's a
great way to connect [music] with
people. You might see here, um, on a
little deeper level. Um, I attended one
on a Sunday morning. We're in a book
club. I just dropped my phone,
which I'm going to need in just a
second. So, um,
yeah, sorry. meet [music] up groups. Um
they're a great thing. I highly
encourage you to uh get involved in one.
Um and finally, let me send you into
this week with a benediction.
If you can put yourself into a posture
to receive or just open your heart to
these words.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day. So as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs and lows and everything in
between,
go filled with the assurance that you
[music]
are loved.
You are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
a desire to extend those same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed and
we'll see you [music] next Sunday.
We are [singing] known [music] in love.
known in love. [singing] We are [music]
known in love by you.
[music] We [singing] are known in love.
>> Known in love. [music and singing] We
are known in love by you.
>> We are known [music and singing]
in love by you.
You did that.
>> That was one of my favorite